[Music]
when you think about it
streaming is really weird you're sitting
there
alone in a room for eight hours a day
trying to make ends meet
and the only people around to comfort
you are randomly spamming your screen
with nonsense
it requires a special kind of motivation
to wake up every day
ready to bear all for twitch's biggest
trolls
it's a day in and day out marathon to go
from just a handful of
friendly eyes watching to tens of
thousands of fans
from jankass webcams and mics to fully
produced
mind-blowing broadcasts oh my god
there's a giant cockroach right there
i gotta say kyrie
and then when you finally get to the top
what's waiting for you
stream snipers ruining your games haters
commandeering your chat to tell you your
trash
and live stream fails waiting to
immortalize your first major mistake
why is the butter on the radio oh
oh my god oh my god oh my god
no really that's how i
die oh my god i'm [ __ ] stupid
i'm [ __ ] stupid
this life just isn't for the faint of
heart
it's not for regular people it requires
something more something that makes you
get out of bed
light up your room like a hollywood set
and go to work
every day for the always extreme felix
xqc len
gel that motivation comes in the form of
the juice
there's no clear definition of what the
juice is because the juice is whatever
you make it
so where does this metaphorical liquid
come from
and how has xqc wielded it to become one
of the most popular streamers
on the planet what's happening
your mom is fat fat hoe
feels good
[Music]
so what is it that makes xqc so
completely and
utterly watchable well he yells
he screams
he absolutely pounds coca-cola's
coco coco
he plays weird games
and he says and does some seriously
bizarre [ __ ]
he kept insulting me in my brain and my
smith is
welcome to the jungle thanks for
subscribing
the reason we like xqc is that he's
exactly
how we all wish we could be sometimes a
completely unfiltered version
of himself essentially he's the twitch
viewer who made it
level melted
[Music]
he plays what he wants he consumes
whatever content his audience wants him
to
and he offers spicy takes on practically
anything that crosses his mind
120 euro jesus
oh my god all right he's next because i
don't want to roast some chat because
they're like they're like actual
children dude and i feel bad in a
bullying child on the stream it's kind
of weird
but jesus christ the lack of stuff i
wanted although xqc now spends his time
streaming variety games or just chatting
to 30 000 people every night
his gaming career actually started in
the overwatch league
when blizzard announced the inaugural
overwatch league season
xqc was signed to the dallas fuel as a
main tank
at the time he was known as one of the
best winston players in the
world and dallas was an early favorite
to dominate after assembling what many
people thought
was the best north american roster
possible and while the fuel
didn't burn as brightly as everyone had
expected xqc
quickly cemented himself as a fan
favorite in the competitive scene
[Applause]
and naturally as a professional esports
player who twitch chat
loved to laugh at his own channel grew
in popularity
he developed a reputation for streaming
all day practicing with his team through
dinner and then going live again
before bed xqc is a spaz who can somehow
barely keep his
life together xqc was growing not just
because of overwatch but
also because his stream was a breeding
ground for insanity
it is my stream now no dude it's monday
i work with it
it's my stream no it's
[Applause]
leave shame
and in many ways he was becoming overly
excuse-y
he was willing to say or do anything at
any time
for a laugh or a meme and while his
audience loved that about him
it ultimately came at the cost of his
esports career
xqc is not reliable enough to be playing
a roster we
tried to play with him stage one then he
got suspended okay and then he comes in
we stop playing with him we start
practicing him
with him really hard and really want him
to be a part of the team and he gets
himself suspended again and it's like
how can you play with that as a team for
most esports personalities
this would have been a devastating end
but for xqc
it was only the beginning he had been
unshackled
from the pr driven expectations of
esports
and found himself now able to fully
commit to his streaming audience i
said it would be a good boy
hell no i won't be a good boy
and then came the juice there's no clear
definition of what the juice is
because the juice is whatever you make
it
can't be anything nobody can define what
it is for you
you know what the juice is right for me
like sometimes
i think the juice is
that's my juice as you just heard from
the man himself
the juice is what drives xqc it's the
intangible liquid that drives him to
become
the ultimate sociopath in among us to
entertain people for hours on end
to sleep on stream and get away with it
and just be altogether
more outrageous than any other streamer
out there
after a night of playing like wow all
night i would put my gun
like on uh on a post-it you know you
know like a post-it note
do you write notes on it and then make
like a small mountain like uh like this
big
of gums and after like months i realized
that for some reason
when the guns stack up with like the
saliva whatever they gain like a new
taste
all right sonny that's enough just pick
that up
in many ways this fictional substance
defines the very
essence of an xqc stream he never turns
it off
he's always got more to say and he's not
afraid to apply that personal philosophy
to anything
if in life you always show up right
and you get a participation ticket every
day and what you do
at some point you'll hit the juice right
even if you show up and you don't get it
100 times in a row
maybe at some point you'll get it right
but if you have no
names in the hats how can you expect
to be drawn from the hat gf of one year
broke up with me
feeling like [ __ ] at least have your
stream to cheer me up pick hands
i feel like you put too much value into
someone else
if you cared the same amount about that
you just lost
about yourself you'd be the most jacked
intelligent
educated successful person on earth but
you you you export too much you export
your careness
you give to everyone else you give
everything you forget to give up
about yourself get the jews what are you
waiting for
after leaving professional overwatch and
giving everything he had to streaming
xqc's popularity soared he jumped from 3
000 to 40 000 concurrent viewers in
three years
he literally got kicked out of an
international esports league
and then became bigger than the league
itself and at the heart of it
was the juice
[Music]
i'm simon yeah
moxie
[Music]
happy birthday to felix from the boys
thank you
and as with most things on the internet
the juice
wasn't left to be a shockingly profound
footnote
to the story of xqc no instead
it's been turned into a twitch emote
used to refer to people as
juicers as both a compliment and an
insult and of course
there's even a song about it
now if this is the first time that
you've heard someone combine
xqc and the proper noun the juice i
wouldn't blame you
for being a little confused after all
you have a manic
unpredictable and at times chaotic super
streamer
compelled to greatness by a personal
philosophy steeped in a mystical
beverage
but it does explain a lot i mean when
you log onto twitch
you're signing up for chaos it's this
bizarre mix of people doing just about
whatever they want
in front of a camera and xqc stream is
at the forefront of that
it's almost impossible to explain what
draws the masses to this boisterous
french canadian
sure he's funny he's energetic and he's
consistent
but the fact that he doesn't give a [ __ ]
what everybody expects from him
is ultimately refreshing literally the
only reason why they watch him is
just to get mad at something did it even
overwatch
it it's bad it's been four nights normie
if you're a running variety game it's
boring
it's too slow chat's dead chat's slow no
music
it's not motivating enough too much
story not enough gameplay it's
repetitive
there's always something dude there's
always something to do
but just chill okay and and cross your
fingers and hope
i know what the [ __ ] i'm doing okay i am
a 60 000 head
i know i'm doing it i'm stinging the
boat the best i can
i got the crew on the bottom dude i'm
swaddling that [ __ ] up
max speed at 16 000 knots shut the [ __ ]
i'm gonna enjoy the ride you talk
whether you subscribe to xqc's juice
philosophy or not
it's hard to deny the impact that it's
had on his career
in a matter of years it transformed him
from being an
edgy up-and-coming personality into
twitch's
most unhinged poster boy and while the
juice
has been responsible for some of his
less than stellar
moments it can also be credited as a
source for some of his greatest ones too
i hope you've a nice day i hope you have
a nice day
i hope your day is great and you spend
time with the wheel you love it
and nothing wrong happens because you're
a good person
and at the end of the day in spite of
his flaws that's what makes xqc
such an endearing streamer it's that
unbridled passion he directs into
everything that he does
that makes him worth keeping an eye on
even when it gets him into trouble
he's an enigmatic yet inspiring figure
among his peers
one who has proven that he can remain
successful while unapologetically
being himself
[Music]
holy [ __ ] the juice and xqc
are one in the same it's a symbiotic
relationship where one
simply can't exist without the other and
even if you don't indulge in his juicy
dogma
you can bet your ass that he has no
plans of ever giving it up
is this working holy [ __ ]
refreshing the score esports tonic
it's not fresh cabbage doesn't smell so
good dude so i can't even imagine what
rotten cabbage smells like
[ __ ] like you're performing anal probes
in your room
please don't use that though the juice
for real though the monkey colosseum
poop gets thrown in human coliseum not
as much
do you ever um
like my cat